Bitte schön.
Guten Abend. Mein Name ist Felix. Ich bin hier, den Dienstabend der Erzien.
Ich habe ein paar Fragen zu Ihnen gesprochen.
Aber zuerst möchte ich wissen, wie Sie heißen.
Hallo, Guten Abend. Mein Name ist Manuela Schwesig.
Könnten Sie Ihre Vor- und Nachnamen beirren?
Mein Vornamen ist Manuela, Martha, Anton Nordpol, Udo, Emil, Ludwig, Anton.
Manuela, ganz einfach.
Ja, und Nachname?
Schwesig, SCH, Walter, Emil, Sigrid, Ida, Gustav, Schwesig.
Okay, Frau Schwesig.
Ja.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 74 Jahre alt.
74?
Ja.
Und wann sind Sie geboren?
Oh, Sie fragen mich Sachen. Am 21. April.
Mhm.
1950.
Wie groß sind Sie, Frau Schwesig?
Schwesig, bitte.
Ich bin 1,65 m groß und wiege 75 kg.
So, Frau Schwesig, was kann ich für Sie tun?
Also, Frau Doktor, ich mache mir viele Sorgen in den letzten Tagen.
Ich mache eigentlich immer viel Sport, bin eigentlich sehr fit
und habe ansonsten nie Probleme gehabt.
Aber jetzt seit einigen Tagen bekomme ich immer wieder
so einen göttelförmigen Druck auf der Brust.
Ja, das zieht man nach rechts, mal nach links.
Ich weiß nicht, was es ist.
Das kommt und geht und das macht mich fast schon sehr panisch.
Haben Sie dabei Brust, Schmerzen?
Ja, das ist so ein komisches Gefühl.
Ich kann es nicht sagen, ob es jetzt ein Schmerz ist
oder ein Druck.
Es ist von allem ein bisschen etwas.
Aber ich habe schon so ein Druckgefühl.
Haben Sie auch Luftnot?
An sich nicht, nein.
Ich weiß dann nicht, ist es etwas auf der Brust,
sind es die Ribben, ist es die Muskulatur?
Ich bekomme dann auch immer ein bisschen Angst dabei
und ich weiß dann nicht, ob ich weiter Sport machen soll
oder nicht.
Ja, das ist so ein Ding, der mir druckt.
Ich kann Ihre Sorgen gut verstehen.
Gibt es etwas, das Ihre Beschwerden liendert
oder verschlimmert?
Nein, an sich nicht.
Es kommt und geht.
Manchmal ist der Blutdruck auch mal etwas hoch.
Da habe ich mal gemessen.
Normalerweise ist er immer so bei 130, zu 70.
Zuletzt war es bei 160, zu 80.
Da bekomme ich auch immer Angst und Panik.
Eigentlich war ich vor zwei Jahren beim Kardiologium,
da war alles in Ordnung, hat er mir gesagt.
Mein Haushalt hat auch eine EKG geschrieben,
aber trotzdem macht man sich da ein bisschen Sorgen.
Sind diese Druckgefühle immer da
oder gehen Sie wieder weg?
Wenn ich bei Ihnen bin, dann sind Sie nur ganz leicht.
Aber heute Mittag, da war es etwas heftiger.
Diese Druckgefühl,
ist diese Druckgefühl von etwas abhängig,
z.B. in Atmen oder Belastung?
Nein, kann ich nicht sagen.
Ich komme manchmal, wenn ich Sport mache oder danach.
Aber z.B. gestern Abend war ich zu Hause,
dann ist es auch gekommen, wenn ich jetzt überhaupt keinen Sport gemacht habe.
Es kommt mehr, wenn ich mich belaste, wenn ich Sport mache.
Ich mache ein bisschen Fitness, ein bisschen Fahrrad,
ein bisschen Gerätetraining.
Ich möchte mich fit halten, wissen Sie?
Aber jetzt, ich weiß nicht, woher das kommt.
Sind Ihre Beschwader langsam oder plötsch aufgetreten?
Ja, ich würde sagen, schon eher plötzlich.
Hatte sich schon mal in die Beschwader?
Ja, bis vor zwei Wochen hatte ich gar nichts.
Zwei Tage bis zwei Wochen?
Bis zwei Wochen, ich wollte sagen.
Aber seit einigen Tagen sind Ihre Beschwader schlechter geworden?
Ja, das ist richtig.
Haben Sie Herrstraßen, Herrstolpen oder Ähnliches?
Ja, das ist das Anspreche.
Gestern Vormittag, am Morgen, als ich aufgestanden bin,
da hatte ich das Gefühl, ich habe auch ein bisschen schnellen Puls.
Das hat mir auch Angst gemacht.
Kann es vielleicht an dem Kolesterol liegen, Frau Doktor?
Ja, es könnte auch sein.
Leicht erhöhtes Kolesterol, so hoch ist es jetzt nicht, aber auch ein bisschen komisch.
Ja, es könnte es sein.
Ich habe das Kolesterol mal verursacht,
die Verengung der Blutgefäße.
Vielleicht können Sie diese Druckgefüll.
Lass Sie sie immer kontrollieren.
Der Doktor meinte, die sind jetzt nicht so schlimm,
nur ganz leicht erhöht, aber ich weiß es nicht.
Das EKG setzt beim Hausarzt mal auch in Ordnung.
Aber ich mache mir ein bisschen Sorgen, aber etwas ab.
Das kann ich Sie gut verstehen.
Nach diesem Gespräch können wir alles kontrollieren.
Das wäre sehr schön, ja, danke.
Haben Sie diese Beschwerden auch im Lohen?
Manchmal, ja, jetzt vielleicht einigen Tagen,
aber es ist auch unabhängig von der Belastung.
Aber wie gesagt, meistens ist es mehr, wenn ich Sport mache,
wenn ich es so überlege, dann ist es doch mehr, wenn ich mich anstrengere.
Haben Sie bemerkt, dass Sie geschwollene Beine haben?
Nein, nein, also ich habe an den Füßen und an den Waden
keine Übungen oder Schwellungen.
Haben Sie vielbeals Schiffdahlfluss oder Nachtschweiß?
Nein, nein.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Er ist einfach zu gut, er hat Essen und Trinken, ist eigentlich ganz okay.
Haben Sie in der letzten Zeit Ab- oder Zuge genommen?
Nein, nein.
Ich versuche ein bisschen abzunehmen, obwohl ich jetzt doch so viel Sport treibe,
nehme ich nicht so richtig ab.
Ich bin eigentlich gleich geblieben, ja.
Sind Ihnen schwindelig oder haben Sie schwarz vor den Augen?
Ob es mir schwindelig ist, nein.
Ist Ihnen übel oder haben Sie schon mal Albrochen?
Ich habe auch nicht übelkeit, wie soll ich das sagen, manchmal.
Aber ich habe das Gefühl, ich habe auch ein bisschen viel Luft im Magen.
Das ist ein bisschen gebläht, habe ich das Gefühl.
Schlafen Sie gut, Frau Schwiesig?
Ja, normalerweise schon.
Haben Sie Probleme mit dem Stuhlgang oder was erlassen?
Nein, ich habe nicht.
Leiten Sie an irgendwelche Vorerkrankungen?
Ich habe einen bekannten hohen Blutmug, aber der ist bisher eigentlich immer ganz gut eingestellt gewesen.
Wir sind sich neben einem Medikament, das habe ich vergessen Ihnen zu sagen.
Das nennt sich, glaube ich, Kandesatan, meine ich.
Ja, müsste Kandesatan sein.
Erinnert Sie sich, welche Dosierung hat diese Medikamente?
Ich glaube, das waren 8 Milligramme, meine ich.
Ich nehme jeden Morgen und jeden Abend, aber wenn der Blutdruck zu niedrig ist,
dann lasse ich das auch mal weg.
Ist Ihre Blutdruck gut eingestellt, oder?
Ja, es war bisher eigentlich ganz gut, immer so bei 110 bis 170 oder 120 bis 80.
Sie haben auch eilhöchte Blutverdweite?
Also, das Cholesterin ist, glaube ich, bei 210 und mein Arzt meinte, die Grenze ist bei 200.
Das ist jetzt nicht so hoch, denke ich, aber...
Nehmen Sie dagegen keine Medikamente, oder?
Ich mag keine Tabletten, also der Doktor wollte mir nochmal Tabletten geben,
aber ich nehme die Tabletten.
Seit wann haben Sie eilhöchte Blutdruck?
Das ist schon lange, das ist schon ein Schraubis seit über 20 Jahren.
Leiden Sie noch andere Erkrankungen?
Bitte?
Leiden Sie noch weiter vor Erkrankungen?
Nach anderen Erkrankungen, ja, ich habe seit 4, 5 Jahren Probleme mit meinem rechten Knie.
Da habe ich Arthrose, aber ich will es noch nicht operieren lassen.
Herr Dr. Meinsmann soll es operieren, aber ich will das nicht.
Okay, wo dann Sie schon mal operieren?
Ich glaube, als Kind bin ich mal an Blinddam operiert worden.
Vor 5 Jahren wurde die Gebärmutter entfernt, weil ich so viele Myoen hatte.
Sie schreiben aber viel auf, Herr Dr. Was machen Sie denn da?
Ich muss über Sie so viele Informationen sammeln und gleichzeitig diese Informationen nutzen.
Können Sie sich das alles merken?
Ja, ich brauche viele Informationen.
Aber das bleibt hier, das bekommt keiner?
Ja, nur unter uns.
Okay.
Machen Sie sich keine Sorgen.
Nehmen Sie regelmäßig außerkandesaltern ein Medikament oder weil bedarf ein Medikament ein?
Also wenn ich mal Schmerzen habe, dann nehme ich mal Paracetamol.
Oh ja, das weiß ich nicht. Paracetamol?
500, vielleicht.
Also das ist halt das, was man in der Apotheke so unter Rezept bekommen kann.
Sind Ihnen Allergien oder Unfallstrecklichkeiten bekannt?
Allergien, ich hatte mal vor vielen Jahren mal ein Antibiotikum bekommen,
als ich eine Lungenentzündung hatte.
Und da habe ich auf eines der Medikamente allergisch reagiert, aber ich weiß nicht mehr, wie der Name ist.
Okay. Wie reagieren Sie gegen diese Medikamente?
Das ist damals ganz schlimm.
Ich habe einen ganz roten Ausschlag am ganzen Körper gehabt.
Ich habe schlecht Luft bekommen.
Mein Kreislauf ist zusammengebrochen.
Also das war, glaube ich, fast eine Schockzymtomatik.
Ja.
Jetzt möchte ich über Ihre Genugmittel und etwas erfahren und frage, wie Sie sich rauchen.
Nein.
Haben Sie niemals geraucht, oder?
Oh, ganz selten nein.
Okay. Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Also ich trinke sehr gerne mal in Wein.
Wie viel und wie oft trinken Sie?
Ich würde sagen, abends trinke ich gerne mal einen Wein, so ein Glas Wein pro Abend.
Das kommt glaube ich schon hin.
Okay. Bitte nehmen Sie diese Frage nicht, Person.
Es ist eine Routinefrage, die ich jede Patientin stellen muss.
Haben Sie Erfahrung mit Drogen?
Nein. Drogen habe ich gar nicht gemacht.
Okay. Als nächstes sprechen wir über Ihre Familienkrankheiten.
Leiden Ihre Eltern irgendwann Schafor-Einkrankungen und leben Sie noch?
Nein. Meine Eltern sind schon verstorben.
Aber Sie hatten natürlich schon ein paar Sachen.
Mein Vater hatte ein Prostategräbs.
Später hatte er noch ein Dickdumpgräbs bekommen und ist danach verstorben.
Meine Mutter hatte Diabetes, hatte auch Großkolosterien und auch Wundlodruckerben.
Erinnern Sie sich, wie alt waren Ihre Eltern, als Sie verstorben sind?
Also mein Vater war um die 85 und meine Mutter ist mit 78 Jahren verstorben.
Okay. Haben Sie Geschwister?
Ich habe noch eine Schwester.
Ist sie gesund?
Ja, eigentlich ist sie viel gesünder.
Was machen Sie von beruflich vorausschließlich?
Ich bin Rentnerin.
Ich bin Rentnerin, genau.
Und habe früher als Erzieherin gearbeitet.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Mein Mann ist vor zehn Jahren verstorben.
Ich wohne alleine.
Vor zehn Jahren.
Er hatte leider einen Herzinfarkt bekommen.
Deswegen macht mir das auch immer wieder Angst, wenn ich irgendwie Beschwerden bekomme.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Nein.
Sind Sie gegen Kinderkrankheiten und die anderen Krankheiten vollständig geimpft?
Zum Beispiel COVID-19, Hepatitis, Televon.
Mein Haus macht das alles.
Ich bin gegen alles geimpft, dass sie momentan notwendig ist.
Okay. Waren Sie in den letzten sechs Monaten im Ausland?
Nein.
Ich habe alle meine Fragen schon gestalt.
Haben Sie Fragen oder mögen Sie etwas hinzuckeln?
Nein, ich würde mich freuen, wenn Sie herausfinden können, was das ist.
Und dann habe ich im Moment keine Fragen.
Okay.
Jetzt muss ich Sie körperlich untersuchen und etwas Blut abnehmen.
Gegendem falls eine Brust rund gehen und Bauch-Ultraschall durchführen.
Sobald ich die alle Untersuchung-Ergebnisse bekomme, kann ich etwas Ihnen genaueres sagen.
Okay. Also, das machen Sie alles heute noch?
Ja, ich glaube.
Aber ich bitte Sie, um einen Platz in Wathezim-Mosnemen, dann rufe ich Sie wieder auf.
Okay, ansatz. Vielen Dank.
Gerne. Bis dann.
Danke schön.
Haben Kollegen oder Kolleginnen noch andere Fragen?
Eine Kollegin hat geschrieben, haben Sie Taubhaus geführt oder krippen im Bereich der Schmerzen?
Auf der Brust oder wo soll ich krippen sein?
Ich denke, beide. Ja, Brust.
Taubhaus geführt auf der Brust, es sticht unter der Rippe manchmal, wie ein Messer stechen.
Manchmal ist es ein Druck, manchmal ist es eher so, dass wir ein Messer stechen.
Aber das hat nicht gefragt, oder?
Bitte?
Ein Messer stechen.
Wie schätzen Sie das?
Im Moment so bei 3-4.
Im Status, nicht gefragt.
Doch, hat sie.
Haben Sie eine Funktion gegen Gyytur-Rosa?
Ich weiß nicht, aber der Haushalt hat alles gemacht.
Ich denke, alle, die Fragen gestellt werden, könnten wir als erstes anfangen?
Eine Frage hat es vergessen.
Ich habe gesagt, ich habe eine Allergie auf Antibiotika, sie hat nicht nach dem Namen gefragt.
Welche Antibiotika?
Moxiklav.
Guten Abend, Herr Oberarzt.
Ich habe eine neue Patientin gesehen, die ich Ihnen vorstellen möchte.
Haben Sie seit dafür?
Aber natürlich, bitte schön.
Es handelt sich um Frau Manuela Schwiesig.
Sie ist 74 Jahre alt, 1,65 m groß und 75 kg schwer.
Sie stellte sich vor seit einigen Tagen bestehendem,
auf der Brust,
und vielleicht leichter Schmerzen.
Diese Beschweiten sind plötzlich aufgetreten
und die Beschweiten sind belastet abhängig.
Sie gelitten sich manchmal noch im Ruhe auf.
Die Schmerzintensität liegt bei 3 bis 4 von 10 auf einer Schmerzskala.
Die Ennihe beschwerden haben die Patienten schon seit 2 Wochen.
Die Patienten sieht ängstlich aus.
Sie erwähnte, dass sie Techi-Kardie und auch erhöhte Bruthoch-Alterie-Hypertonie hat.
Sie hat auch Brutdruck zu Hause gemessen und war bis 160, so 160, so 60.
Sie hat gesagt, sie ist Techi-Kardie gewesen.
Wie hoch war die Techi-Kardie?
Ich habe sie nicht gemessen, aber sie erwähnte, dass sie eine Herzrasen hatte.
Sie haben aber nicht nachgeschaut.
In der vegetative Anamnese erwähnte sie, er gab eine Nausea und eine Bileung.
Besüglich Vorerkrankungen und Voreporationen seien die Folgende bekannt.
Seit 20 Jahren hat die Arterie-Hypertonie mit Kandesartan 8 mg
mit Konzertrose in der Rechtenknie.
Dagegen nehmen sie 500 mg bei Bedarf.
Als Kind sei eine Epandectomie erfolgt und vor 5 Jahren eine Hysteroctomie
wegen Utterusmiome erfolgt.
Bei ihr ist eine Amoxicillinallergie bekannt, die mit Anaphylaktischer Schock reagiert.
Nikotin und Drogenkonsum wurden verneint, aber sie trinken ein Glas Wein abends.
In der Familienanamnese er gab eine Prostatakarsinom und Kolonkarsinom bei Fatah
und Diabetes-Menutus-Tübsweih, Hypertolesterinemi und Arterie-Hypertonie bei der Mutha.
Die beiden Ertöne sind schon verstorben.
Sie haben eine gesunde Schreste.
Die Patientin ist Rentnerin, so vor Habersie als Erzieherin gearbeitet.
Seit 10 Jahren ist sie verwidert.
Ihre Ehemann sei am Mucardinfarkt verstorben.
Sie macht auch Sorgen, ob sie einen Herzinfarkt haben.
Sie zeigt es los.
Die manamnistischen Angaben dueten am Bestand auf eine Panikatakie hin.
Als Differenzialdiagnostisch kommen Anginapectoris oder Mucardinfarkt
und chronische Pankratitis.
Vielleicht leber sie rose in Betracht.
Eine ganz einfache Gastritis.
Wenn ich mich richtig erinnere, haben Sie auch gesagt,
die epigastrischen Lehrungen.
Vielleicht ist auch deswegen Gastritis oder Ulkus-Ventrug in Betracht.
So weiter eine Abklärung würde ich so erst die Patientin körperlich untersuchen
und gleichzeitig Vitalparameter messen.
Dann nehme ich Blut ab.
Bei der Erlebnung und Versuchungen
achte ich besonders darauf.
Blutbild, Entzündungsparameter, Transaminase, Amylase-Ripase.
Nehmen Sie jetzt noch einen Ring dem Herz.
Welche Entzüme sind das?
Wie heißen die Herzentzüme?
Troponin.
Dann eine Röntgen-Torax und Abdominal-Ultraschall durchführen.
Welche Differenzialdiagnose muss man noch denken bei diesen älteren Frauen?
Intervantinfarkt.
Alles mit dem Herzen, ein Infarkt.
Aber dann hätte man wahrscheinlich, wenn es so akut ist im EKG, etwas gesehen.
Aber da war es.
Sie haben mit dem EKG geschrieben, da war nichts.
Nichts, glaube ich.
Keine Ische mehr.
Eine Dyssektion als Differenzialdiagnose.
Was haben meistens alte Menschen am Rücken?
Rückenschmerzen.
Lumbagi.
Das ist eher im BWS-Bereich, also ein BWS-Syndrom,
Ostfäbes-Körper-Syndrom.
Vielleicht eine Interkostale Neuralgie, also ganz etwas Einfass.
Ja, die Frage war, glaube ich, haben gesehen.
Blumenemboly, muss man auch mal denken.
Pericarditis.
Ist mir nicht klar, heutzutage muss man auch daran mal denken.
Fällt Ihnen noch etwas ein, Frau Doktor?
Noch mal.
Fällt Ihnen noch etwas ein?
Nee, vielleicht als therapeutisch kann ich etwas sagen.
Ja, natürlich, bitte schön.
Was würden Sie vorschlagen?
Ja, nach Bestätigung der Diagnose
fange ich mit der folgenden Therapie anfangen.
Erste Massnahme ist die Berührung der Patientin.
Deswegen kann ich die Patientin empfehlen,
zum Beispiel Atemfrequenz zu sehen.
Oder in einer Tür zu atmen.
Sie gehen von einer psychischen Problematik aus,
also eine hyperventilation.
Gegenüberfalls mit einer Nasensonder-Sauerstuch-Eben.
Das könnte man mal probieren, während Sie der Notaufnahme ist.
Und eine Angst-Solytika.
Woran denken Sie, alle Angst-Solytika?
Wenn Sie diese Pienen.
Als Dauer-Therapie kann ich auch Angst-Solytika
oder Antidepressiva verschreiben.
Und ein psychologisches Konzil.
Die psychoterepie kann ich auch empfehlen,
besonders Verhaltenstherapie und Selbsthilfegruppen.
Das ist sehr hilfreich.
Das können wir den Patienten vorschlagen.
Sehr gut.
Herr Dr. vielen Dank.
Ich bedanke mich auch.
Wir waren ein bisschen aufgeregt,
machen einige grammatikalische Fehler.
Obwohl Sie das wissen.
Der die singular Plural Einzahl mehr zahlen.
Ich glaube, das ist ein bisschen die Aufregung.
Aber sonst sehr gut.
Ich denke, die Patientin hatte heute auch eine gewisse Panikattacke.
Sie hatte immer wieder ein bisschen Blutdruckerhöhung.
Aber ganz klar kann man das natürlich nicht sagen.
Nur ein EKG und Propolin.
Vielleicht braucht man doch mal einen Herzkartier.
Ich mein Sie ist 74 Jahre alt.
Das ist natürlich alles möglich.
Okay, wunderbar.
Vielen Dank.
Dann ist die Prüfung.
Am 4. Juni.
10 Tage.
Okay.
Sehr gut.
Vielen Dank.
Ich habe eine emotionelle Belastung in letzter Zeit.
Ja, natürlich.
Ich reg mich über die Nachrichten auf.
Überall wenn man Nachrichten anschaut, wird immer noch über den Krieg berichtet.
Das ärgert mich schon ein bisschen.
Ich möchte wissen, wie lange dauert diese Druckgefühl, wenn Sie...
Tagstück ist es eher 1-2 Stunden, aber nachts ist es dann länger.
Wie oft dauert diese Druckgefühl seit 2 Wochen?
Ja, fast jeden Tag.
Jeden Tag, danke.